because like i mean when i was growing
up in school like i was i
swear the only guy was interested in
like any asian culture and it felt
really weird because like and no one
gave a [ __ ] everyone cared about like
the football that was on yeah cool i
mean but like now it's almost like you
know there's almost a
like a fetishization of like japanese
culture exactly i love
japanese so if i if i grew up in the
states during
now i'd be like
i feel like i was growing i grew up in
the wrong era because like
kids now find anime did you just say
that no because like kids now find anime
cool and [ __ ] and i'm just like bruh
where where were all these kids when i
was like secretly watching anime yeah
we were growing up you get bullied for
watching dragon ball z but now you get
bullied for only watching dragon ball z
wow you only watch dragon ball talk
about this for another two hours
like we can make another youtube video
just for this
topic this is an important topic yeah
honestly because it's like
because i felt that way too like in
australia because i was the only kid
with
any kind of asian blood anymore like i
don't look asian
but when you're in a school that is 99.9
white even that one percent of asian
look
sticks out like crazy yeah so and then
you know i had the exact same thing over
here like i don't look japanese at all
so when people [ __ ] you know when i
would say konnichiwa they'd [ __ ]
nihongo jozu mean an instant i'm like
it's not hard to say konnichiwa bro
like i say so much more i can say so
much more but you don't even give me the
opportunity
to give that to you yeah so it was like
what the [ __ ] do i do yeah it's funny
how times have changed because
i remember talking to my cousin uh who
so who has a son who's going to school
now and he's really into sports he's
like
he's like a super jock basically it's
kind of like the opportunity
kind of kind of like the opposite of me
a giga jock basically
but i remember she was telling me about
how he got bullied in school right
because he didn't joke no no yeah for
being a joke because he didn't play
fortnite
so this so that's so funny
my mom was telling me the same thing so
mike yeah am i younger yeah yeah yeah so
my younger nephew he got bullied for not
playing fortnight so
one day he decides to play fortnite and
then he still got bullied
because he had the default skin yeah my
mom works in a primary school like kids
for like i don't know
six and 12. she was telling me that
these the kids were getting bullied
because they didn't have any skins in
fortnight
i'm just like i was like because when i
when i was growing up
when i was that age it was always the
kid who was the fastest yeah he was like
the coolest yeah yeah yeah but when i
actually became the fastest kid it
wasn't cool anymore and i was like what
the [ __ ]
and then you know i was always good at
video games i got bullied for playing
video games but now i've been like i'd
have been so cool in school
we all go through that right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
chasing you know the the trend trying to
be no no no no
we were ahead of the generation yeah
yeah we were you were so fast that you
out you outran
yeah i quickly i quickly realized i'm
like [ __ ] everyone else i
i like what i like yeah i'm gonna do
what i want we set the trends now
we need to transfer we the trend now